the wii u and 3ds are home to the likes
of super mario legend of zelda and
pokemon but what are the best-selling
nintendo games on those platforms
nintendo has revealed its top first
party games as of december 31st 2015
finishing in first place on wii u is
mario kart 8 with over seven million
copies sold that's thanks to bundles and
digital downloads the top 5 also
includes new super mario bros u nintendo
land super mario 3d world and super
smash bros all of which sold around five
million as for the 3ds pokemon X&Y
topped the list with a whopping 14 and a
half million copies behind it are Mario
Kart 7 Pokemon Omega Ruby and alpha
sapphire super mario 3d land and new
super mario brothers to any of those
surprise you Nintendo's overall revenue
when profit margin were down for that
selling period but the numbers on those
wii u and 3ds games sure sound good you
can check out the full top 10 lists on
gamespot then when Nintendo has more
announcements you'll already be in the
right place